there's a lot of people that said
Bitcoin failed as an inflation hedge I
would actually argue the complete
opposite the team at reflexivity
research put out a brand new report
summarizing all of 2022 and doing a
little bit of a look forward for 2023.
the initial Domino that set everything
off was you had you know FTX that was
basically trying to act as this kind of
white knight in the space and coming to
save the day it did fool everybody but
then you know November comes when you
look forward to 2023 and into 2024 how
do you feel are you bullish are you
cautiously kind of optimistic yeah sure
I think all right guys bang bang I've
got will here the young wizard uh you
and the team at reflexivity research put
out a brand new report summarizing all
of 2022 uh and doing a little bit of a
look forward uh for 2023 uh for Bitcoin
and crypto assets and also the macro
environment so I thought it'd be great
just to kind of Dive Right into maybe
we'll start with macro uh obviously
inflation was a major story over the
last two and a half three years how do
you break down where we are in that
inflation story uh and where we've been
yeah absolutely it's a great question
you know if we just backtrack to early
2020 you know we had the largest
liquidity insertion into you know the
the broader you know economy then I
think we've ever seen in history at
least on like a rate of change basis and
you know with that we had kind of a
lagging effect where you know some
people were speculating would we see
inflation bitcoiners of course said that
you know we would uh but it took about
six months until we finally started to
see that be reflected in CPI
um you know a large portion of that also
had to do with the China lockdowns uh
and a lot of the coveted related you
know policies that had kind of gone into
place
um obviously towards the back half of
the year we saw that to be you know
begin to be a big issue uh and in
retrospect you know once Jerome Powell
came out and said hey you know inflation
is no longer transitory that should have
been kind of the signal to to sell
everything in in hindsight which of
course is 2020.
um but you know since then we've seen
the most aggressive uh you know monetary
tightening period in history if we go
back and look at a year over year change
and M2 money supply I think it's the
first year that we've seen a net
negative change and this is a chart that
we put in the report
um you know going back and looking at
this over the last 40 years or 50 years
I don't think we've ever seen such a
sharp decline in the rate of growth and
empty money supply
um also you know at the same time we're
seeing
um you know quantitative tightening from
the FED as well and so the combination
of that is made you know absolute brutal
conditions for you know growth assets
and unfortunately you know Bitcoins got
basketed in with that
um you know I think one thing to keep in
mind and I think we we definitely both
agree on this is that you kind of have
to compartmentalize CPI and M2 money
supply right and so or I should just say
you know broader liquidity conditions
explain that sure so you know when money
comes into the system it doesn't have an
immediate effect right
um you know money comes in through QE
which is basically the FED buying bonds
right and that doesn't immediately
translate to you know the prices of
something at the grocery store
um and you know at the same time also
you know we had a bunch of stimulus
checks that came out in 2020 which added
you know another you know piece on top
of the QE that had been taking place for
the last 10 years
um but there tends to be a big lag
between when the money comes into the
system and when it begins to get
reflected in something like a CPI which
is a lagging indicator by definition
and so I think that's kind of why you
know while bitcoiners were harping on
hey look they printed 40 of all the
money in existence in early 2020 it took
you know five six months for that really
to start you know getting reflected in
in the actual CPI numbers
um and Bitcoin you know performed
accordingly you know there's a lot of
people that said Bitcoin failed as an
inflation hedge
um you know I would actually argue the
complete opposite you know I think what
you need to be looking at is bitcoin's
performance on relative to like the six
six month change or one year change
um in in the M2 money supply rather than
looking at the CPI because it's a direct
what I would say hedge against monetary
debasement instead of necessarily
inflation and so when we look at its
performance since the end of last year
it's done exactly what bitcoiners have
said it would you know would do as
basically a check on Central Bank
um you know monetary policy and so of
course you know as the liquidity tide is
pulled back uh we've seen Bitcoin
perform exactly how you would think it
would do so and you know those
environment uh that environment and so
you know I think you've had a lot of
kind of misguided criticism over the
last year of people saying well you know
inflation is at you know a multi-year
high how come Bitcoin is down what
happened to the you know what happened
to the inflation hedge argument and you
know I think for a lot of bitcoiners
including the two of us I would say it's
performed exactly how you would like it
to so that's interesting because I think
that uh there was this maybe not
confusion but almost uh used as a common
term where people would say inflation
and some people were actually talking
about true CPI you know year-over-year
rate of change and some people were
talking about monetary debasement and
there's obviously a lot of connectivity
there but they are two separate things
and so is your belief today that given
all of the benefit of hindsight that
actually Bitcoin is a monetary
debasement hedge but not necessarily an
inflation hedge or do you think it's
both like how do you kind of come to a
conclusion and say like this is how I
think about Bitcoin today yeah I think
it's the former right and you know you
have certain periods where you know like
what we saw at the end of 2020 into the
beginning of 2021 where you kind of have
an overlap of you know M2 money supply
and the broader you know liquidity
however you want to look at like net
liquidity this is something like Darius
likes to talk about looking at like TGA
accounts as well as M2 money supply you
know you kind of can get this period
where if it's continuing to Trend up for
like a year or so you could have a
several month period where CPI is
ticking up in you know Confluence with
M2 at the same time
um and you know Bitcoin appears to be
you know performing at you know a high
correlation with CPI itself going up uh
but yeah I think I think when you look
at the kind of historical data and the
way that Bitcoins performed looking at
different correlations to things like
the Dixie or like the net liquidity
index or M2 specifically
um I think that those are the the best
mental Frameworks I would say to think
about Bitcoin so when we actually look
at the quantitative tightening that's
been happening
um it or I'm sorry monetary typing
that's been happening um it's very
obvious that interest rates continue to
go up and without speculating on like
where interest rates are going to go
from here is it as simple as just like
when interest rates go up people uh
realize the cost of capital is going up
and therefore they stop buying things
they stop investing in things and
therefore that is what is going to hold
down inflation is it really like just
how the theorist would describe it sure
yeah I think on in a general basis yes
you know you have basically you know the
FED Titans monetary conditions it raises
interest rates which goes down to you
know your large traditional Banks and
then affects all businesses below that
uh and then you know as you have you
know businesses that decide that they
need to cut back they're no longer you
know able to borrow money as easily
right I mean you could borrow basically
any amount of money over the last two to
three years at a zero percent interest
rate I mean look at what Michael Saylor
did right he was able to borrow a
billion dollars for his leveraged
Bitcoin bet at a zero percent interest
rate which is absolutely insane uh we
also had you know negative real yields
which is you're basically paying people
to give you less money in the future
just absolute Madness when you know
you're in that zero interest rate
environment
um but now it's taking place is you know
as you have all these companies uh that
are starting to pull back on spending
they're cutting back on hiring
um you know that trickles down into all
the smaller guys below them and so you
basically get this effect where you as
certain large businesses pull back then
all the small businesses that you know
perhaps they have lending exposure to or
you know they're they're you know uh
they they impact in terms of like their
uh part of their supply chain or
whatever it may be their B2B businesses
things like that uh it all trickles down
and so and then kind of the the final
trickle-down effect of that is that as
businesses cut back and people lose
their jobs then the consumers stop
spending uh and so I think you know over
the next few months we're finally
starting to see that take place uh we
have started to see CPI kind of roll
over over the last few months
um and what you know this is something
that uh Stanley druckenmillers talked
about before
historically like large raises in in CPI
inflation uh don't end until the uh
federal funds rate actually crosses the
CPI number and we're we are getting very
close to that within 50 dips of that
taking place and so you know if we have
another two months of you know a
continued downtrend in CPI
um and you know the FED raises another
25 bips at their next meeting uh then
you I think you know you could see that
kind of crossover of uh the federal
funds rate finally getting above the CPI
number perhaps you know sometime in q1
of this year and when you're talking
about CPI you're talking about the CPI
number or the core CPI number in terms
of that cross correct the the just the
regular CPI CPI and so as that occurs
um the thought process would be okay CPI
comes down the interest rate continues
to go up they cross is there any
analysis that you're aware of in terms
of how long it needs to the interest
rate needs to be above to kind of kill
off the inflation or is it just a simple
Cross of those two numbers uh should
signal that hey we're ahead in the right
direction it's a good question I don't
know the time aspect I don't either it's
fascinating to think about that right
it's like because really it says like
once they cross then should the FED keep
interest rates high for a long period of
time or is it just good enough to cross
leave it there for a quarter or so and
then you can actually start to Pivot
right I think you know that's been kind
of the big debate is you know the
velocity of of you know rate hikes I
think is kind of in the past
um but you know the bigger question on
everyone's mind is how long is the Fed
gonna you know hold rates where they are
according to the Dot Plot it's going to
be towards you know the back half of the
year into 2024 uh but that was the same
case at the end of 2018.
um so you know I will say on one hand
you know the FED has done exactly what
they said they were going to do and I'll
say you know I think we were both kind
of surprised with given where debt to
GDP is at you know how the economy
hasn't um or at least you know things
like looking at the treasury market just
hasn't completely melted down although
we have seen a big sell-off uh markets
have been relatively you know orderly I
would say uh and the sell-off in
equities has been relatively controlled
um you know we haven't had any like
limit down days or anything of the sort
right
um so you know I I think it's it's
something where I've been surprised
personally but I I would also still be
surprised if you know we get to the end
of the year and the fed's holding
interest rates at you know five and a
quarter percent and you know we haven't
seen any type of significant you know
decline in the economy I think also
um you know maybe part of it is you know
all the stimulus checks that went out in
2020 and you know all just the massive
amount of liquidity that got pumped into
the system kind of gives a buffer where
you know maybe the historical numbers of
you know how how quickly it took for CPI
to really start rolling over and you
know how how long it took for things to
really start breaking after the fed you
know raises rates at you know such an
unprecedented rate like we've seen over
the last few years uh you know
potentially that's why I've seen a
couple month delay and some of those
effects that I think both of us are kind
of surprised that we haven't seen
already one of the things that uh you
don't expect in the bottom Market is
lots of volatility right and in the
report you guys talk about the move
index which is kind of the vix for bonds
um and it actually was more volatile
last year than it was during March 2020
crash so there was more volatility in
2022 than there was in the bond market
than in March of 2020 during the
liquidity crisis of the start of the
pandemic era now the only time that the
move index had been more volatile than
it was in 2022 was during the 2008
Global financial crisis and so how do
you think about you know if there's so
much volatility in bonds and yeah we
know the volatility in the stocks and in
crypto and all these other things like
was it just generally a year of
volatility across 2022 and there was no
nowhere for people to hide as investors
hey guys I hope that you're enjoying
this interview before we continue I want
to quickly remind you I'm hosting a
conference March 4th at the Miami Beach
Convention Center that's right it's a
big venue for a big event on March 4th
I'm bringing together some of the
absolute fan favorite guests from the
podcast in this show and we're going to
debate ideas the event is called lyceum
Miami the lyceum was the public
gymnasium in Athens Greece that ancient
gymnasium was important because it's a
place where people from all walks of
life came together to have a war of
ideas you were able to not only
participate in the debates but also
people could sit and watch some of the
smartest people in the world talk about
important issues that's what we're going
to be doing on March 4th at the Miami
Beach Convention Center if you want to
join us go to lyceumiami.com or click on
the link in the description and I'd love
to see you there okay let's get back to
this conversation yeah I think that's
pretty well said you know I think um you
know one mental framework is just
looking at markets in general it's
really just comes down to liquidity and
volatility and so when you pull back
liquidity then volatility increases and
so that's been reflected heavily in the
bond market
um you know it's been the worst year for
bonds I think since like the late 1700s
or something like that
um you know it's funny too when you look
at Bitcoin at one point this year
Bitcoin is actually less volatile than
bonds just looking at the move index uh
bitcoin's volatility is at an all-time
low right now while I'm you know buying
the bond volatility representative done
it through the move index as you
mentioned is you know near you know 10
plus year highs right so
um I do think it's kind of funny just so
it's like as kind of like a just
separate you know fun facts is that this
year Bitcoin volatility actually reached
a lower State than bonds and also
several currencies
um so if you remember you know when
everything went on in the guilt Market
um the pound sold off aggressively right
uh and so during that time period
Bitcoin actually became less volatile
than one of the largest currencies in
the world uh and so I think you know for
a lot of the critics of Bitcoin just on
you know a volatility basis I think a
lot of those things have just been kind
of completely wiped off off the map
right in terms of Bitcoin is too
volatile to be an asset
um you know we've seen every single
major asset class this year show
incredible amount of volatility what do
you think about dollars and like the
dollar Index so the dollar against other
foreign currencies right it seems like
the dollar has continued to strengthen
pretty aggressively uh all throughout
2022 and and what is your expectation in
2023 yeah I think it's interesting now
you're finally starting to see like the
ECB start to raise rates and so I think
with that you know the Dixie itself
which you know to to just remind people
you know it's just a relative gauge of
currency strength against each other
um so you're just looking at a basket of
different currencies relative to the to
the dollar uh and so I think you could
have uh the dxy decline
um you know as these other foreign
currencies are
um you know continuing to on a relative
basis get stronger because the monetary
conditions in those countries are are
getting tighter uh and the US has kind
of surpassed the uh you know rate of the
rate of change in terms of you know rate
hikes whether you know we'll hold them
there as kind of a you know TBD for the
rest of the year
um but in terms of kind of a relative
basis to the other countries you've seen
you know the FED Titan really
aggressively throughout the year
um you know other central banks haven't
you know tightened as aggressively and
kind of caught up and now I think you're
starting to kind of see them uh catch up
you know with Christine Lagarde stating
that you know they finally need to start
to raise rates to try to uh catch up to
the fed and I think part of that is just
currency strength so I think you could
see this this period where perhaps the
Dixie could decline but that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's bullish for
for risk assets right and that's solely
because you know the fed you know you
could have the Dixie decline because the
FED is easing you know monetary
conditions relative to other countries
or you could have it declined because
you know the FED is already raised uh
you know rates and and tight Monica
monetary conditions uh but then you have
the other countries you know stepping in
to catch up uh and so I think with that
you could you could kind of get this
weird period where the Dixie actually
declines but perhaps it's not like super
bullish for risk ass that's like a
historically aspect so I want to read
apart from the report uh specifically
talking about U.S yield curve it says as
it stands the U.S yield curve is now
nearly entirely inverted and other
countries such as Canada are entirely
inverted going into 2023 all indicators
in the bond markets are pointing towards
a significant recession occurring in the
next 12 to 18 months and so when you see
that the yield curves inverting has
historically been a warning sign uh but
to say that there's a significant
recession in the next 12 to 18 months uh
that is something that is becoming much
more of a popular view there's more
people kind of sounding the alarm
there's more people who are pointing to
all these different data points how do
you view the inversion of the U.S yield
curve and then also the inversion of
yield curves around the world and is
that a signal for the severity of how
bad the recession will be or do you just
look at those as two separate data
points but they tend to kind of follow
sequentially yeah I mean it is pretty
weird when you think about it just from
like a first principle standpoint you
know because Banks traditionally borrow
on the short end and lend on the long
end and so when you know you have an
inversion it completely throws off that
Dynamic
um and like you mentioned historically
when you look at kind of like the 10
twos or some people like to look at you
know different uh you know comparisons
of you know different different yields
um you know yeah like you said
historically they have been kind of a a
leading indicator and
um like you said earlier you know I
think we could kind of have this lagging
effect where the tightening that's you
know taking place over the last year
hasn't fully you know gotten reflected
in consumer spending to the extent that
maybe it perhaps will over the next few
months
um but yeah I mean I guess it's kind of
TBD I wish we had uh I wish we had Felix
who's our macro analyst who could give
you a much better uh response than I can
on the macro stuff I love it
um you wrote a whole section uh on
crypto contagion and that was one of the
big stories of 2022. walk me through
kind of in hindsight what is your
evaluation how would you describe to a
friend like okay here's what happened
with contagion in the uh Bitcoin and
crypto industry throughout the year
yeah it's a great question I think like
the first thing to state is that
everything we just described you know
historic rate of you know monetary
tightening
um you know that that's caused
everything in crypto um at least you
know indirectly I think it's important
to just state that you know all the kind
of crypto contagion and credit blow up
that we've seen throughout the year is
all well should all be taken into
context with you know the liquidity tied
pulls back right as Warren Buffett likes
to say when the you know when the tide
comes back you see who's swimming naked
um and that's absolutely what we've seen
in crypto this year
um going back to the beginning of the
year the the kind of initial thing that
you know the initial Domino that set
everything off was Luna
um you know Luna was this at its peak
when you look when you combine UST and
Luna was worth over 60 billion dollars
on paper
um you know not that there was that
amount of you know value that went into
the actual asset that was that was the
peak market cap
um when you looked at kind of Luna and
UST
was this algorithmic stable coin that
was very closely tied with Luna at any
time you could redeem one site for the
other and so the whole kind of system
was whereas you had like Solana was kind
of you know bootstrapped and spearheaded
by you know SPF and the FTX group
you had Avalanche which was essentially
you know spearheaded by three arrows
um Luna was really brought to prominence
through this uh D5 application that was
built on Terra called anchor uh and with
anchor you could basically get 20
risk-free yield
um by you know piling you know your USC
purchasing the UST putting it into the
protocol
um and some people would say it's very
ponzi-like and that you need new market
participants to step in to kind of you
know you to cause that you know yield to
continue to be sustainable
um and what happened was is basically
you know this this works great when you
know there's high confidence in the
system
um but when you do lose confidence in
the system with an algorithmic stable
coin you could have something called a
death spiral and this is something that
you know dokwon was very vocal about
when he came on your podcast he walked
through and said you know this is
something that's possible is you could
have this death spiral but I think you
know he was just a little too confident
in in hindsight about you know the the
validity of the protocol and its
resiliency
um you know I think one thing that I
think it taught people is just you know
when people lose confidence and people
you know are are in a state of fear that
overrides any rational thinking that
maybe they had about uh you know the
protocol they could be you know have a
positive outlook on it for like six to
eight months but as soon as they you
know start to feel feel fearful that
overrides all of that right and so
um you know you had all these Die Hard
Luna people that I think as soon as the
pegs started to break you know they
started to get a little nervous
um and so you had initially this move
down in the peg from like uh a dollar to
like 99 Cents or 98 cents
um it bounced back quickly I don't know
if someone was like defending the peg
like jump or one of those type of
entities uh it's hard to say but um
after that you know it kind of had this
dead cat bounce up back up to like 99
cents on the dollar and then completely
nosedive
um and so you know what happened was
basically uh once once the UST Supply
um was significantly lower than the Luna
Supply
um it was basically locked in that it
was going to be a death spiral uh
because the Redemption mechanism no
longer worked and so that completely
crashed in a matter of two days I think
it went down like 99 or something crazy
so it's crazy looking at the chart now
in hindsight
um and so with that you know I tweeted
out at the time this is the uh this is
crypto's Lehman Brothers moment right in
terms of
um you had this you know huge kind of uh
too big to fail entity that failed uh
and now we're going to see The Fallout
of it and it took some time
um which you know I guess is because you
know people don't immediately want to
kind of poke their neck out and say that
you know they're hurting everyone kind
of wants to assess the damage and see
who pokes their neck out first and uh
then kind of reassess from there but
um you know after after a few months
um you know we began to see all the
effects of that and the first kind of
big Domino to fall after Luna was three
arrows capital
uh three arrows Capital was initially
started as uh currency Arbitrage fund um
they would do different types of
Arbitrage uh through foreign foreign
exchange uh started by suzu and Kyle
Davies we both had like a traditional
banking background
um they ran up uh from my understanding
I think their initial base of capital
was just a few million dollars like two
or three million dollars I ran it up to
on paper Peak 2021 to 18 billion dollars
uh through a lot of venture capital
Investments uh and one of their most
lucrative trades at least that kind of
helped propel them to you know build up
a large Capital base uh was the
grayscale trade
um so at the time you could buy
grayscale
um you could purchase the shares into
the trust and then after six months uh
you'd be able to the shares when I'm not
going to be able to sell them on the
market at the end of 2020 grayscale was
trading at a premium and part of this
was just because I think there's a lot
of entities out there that aren't able
to get direct Bitcoin exposure uh
whether that's because they feel
uncomfortable you know holding their own
keys or some people just for compliance
and Regulatory reasons just like aren't
able to actually hold digital assets and
so you know they they thought that
grayscale was the best way to kind of
get indirect exposure to that uh and so
you you know had I think at the end of
2020 early 2021 uh great scales trading
at like a 20 or 30 premium I think it
was like 30 33 at its peak
um so essentially you know you could
purchase shares uh put them into the
trust and then after six months uh sell
them at a 30 premium this sounds awesome
but what would happen is it just got
completely overcrowded uh and then you
know eventually you had the uh you had
the trust fall into a discount I think
in March of of 2021
um but nonetheless during that kind of
time period from the end of 2020 into
early 2021
um three arrows was able to just borrow
an immense amount of capital and make a
bunch of different you know Venture
Capital Investments That on paper uh you
know showed that they were you know uh
they had a massive p l right I mean they
ran up billions of dollars through these
Venture Capital Investments that were
liquid and they you know were probably
locked in for several years but on paper
they grew the fun to an enormous size
um you know unlike anything you could do
in traditional Finance
um and so what happened was is I think
you know they had collateralized several
of these loans some of them unsecured uh
with their grayscale Holdings
um and it's my it's my understanding
that they they were trying to basically
uh Arbitrage the 20
um uh rate that you could get through
through anchor
um so essentially they had borrowed a
bunch of money from all these lenders
piled it into anchor and the idea was
okay you get you know 20 percent on you
know return on that capital and then you
give uh you know whatever the the rate
is that you're borrowing from from the
lenders you give you know pay that back
and then keep the difference sounds
super straightforward sounds too good to
be true right and it was uh and so what
happened was when Luna got wiped out I
think three hours was probably already
under some pressure from you know the
grayscale trade
uh and I think that was kind of probably
their their final death blow and uh in
an interview after kind of everything
went down Kyle Davies stated also that
you know like I kind of caught them
offside so I think that was kind of the
final arrow in their in their heart that
that put them down
um and so after that then you had this
just immense Panic of uh all this credit
contagion in the space and turned out
that you know the the minimization of
counterparty risk just completely didn't
exist everyone thought you know in the
crypto space that they were exposed to
different people reality everyone was
exposed to the same largest counterparty
which was three arrows and and also to a
lesser extent Alameda uh and so you know
immediately after that you had Voyager
that went down I think Voyager lent them
I forget to figure off time I had over a
billion dollars um unsecured
um uh three arrows also lent uh also
excuse me three arrows also borrowed
from block five uh over a billion
dollars but that was actually uh
collateralized what the issue was it was
collateralized with the grayscale
um with the gbtc shares and so whenever
blockfic took deliver delivery of the
collateral they try to liquidate it they
weren't able to get back the full Mark
to market value of that because you know
gbt's gbtc was already at a discount and
the market was already a liquid
um so you know basically every major
lender including Genesis as well
um all took a hit on once three arrows
went under
um and then through that we started to
see you know continued contagion
throughout the space we also saw Celsius
go under at the time which was also a
byproduct of them having a lot of money
in Risky you know D5 product uh you know
products and you know they experienced
the hack from Badger Dao uh you know a
couple other defy hacks uh and then I
think Luna was probably the final death
blow for them as well
um and so you know throughout the rest
of the year
um you had you know FTX that was
basically trying to act as this kind of
white knight in the space and coming to
save the day after you know three arrows
had gone under and they're like hey look
we're the good guys we're here to we're
here to clean everything up
um and in retrospect I was just a bunch
of posturing from from you know SBF and
and his team
um you know they they had purchased the
uh Voyager assets for I think it was 1.1
billion dollars at the time
um they also extended a credit line to
block five which had basically uh saved
block fi at the time
um and so you know for for several
months people had kind of thought that
FTX was kind of the White Knight of the
space
um and they were kind of the the
responsible ones which is pretty funny
you know in retrospect like at the time
uh the tactics that SBF was using to
like you know puff his chest out and
kind of posture that they were kind of
the adults in the room
um it did fool everybody uh but then you
know November comes and what happens in
November well you had this initial kind
of leak from coindesk which was showing
the balance sheet of Alameda which is
the kind of sister fund which we know is
basically the same entity as FTX now
um which by the way you know I think in
in crypto a lot of the kind of crypto
you know Twitter people always knew that
these two entities were co-mangled not
that not that they were using customer
funds but they they knew you know okay
Alameda probably has some extra trading
Edge that no one else has you know
they're probably getting access to
um you know customer like liquidation
data and things like that but people
just kind of accepted it and they said
okay you know it kind of is what it is
just play by the game right
um but I don't think anyone knew the
kind of extent to what was going on
behind the scenes I think that did you
know catch almost everyone off guard I
think there were a few people in in with
you know uh the benefit of hindsight
that you know were super skeptical but
very few people were saying you know
this is a this is a full-on you know
scam uh and to you know SPF sbf's credit
you know I think uh a lot of the
posturing that they did the political
donations all these types of things the
effect of altruism it really did fool
everybody uh but once that once the
balance sheet got leaked everyone
realized holy cow Alameda is not the
entity that we that we thought they were
because their entire balance sheet was
just a liquid all coins and most of the
all coins were coins that Sam had
literally created so serum oxy
um ftt and also some locked Salon as
well I think like 900 million dollars in
lock Solana
um you know the crazy thing especially
about oxy ftt uh and Serum is that these
were essentially what we like to call
these these uh high fdv low float tokens
uh and what that essentially means is
that you have you know the circulating
Supply and then you have the total
amount a supply that will ever be in
existence
and there was a very small amount of
Supply that was actually circulating
relative to the amount that would ever
come into the market and so you could
have these crazy price moves that cause
a massive run-up in market cap because
there's a very small amount of
circulating Supply that you can actually
access if you want to get exposure to
the asset
um but meanwhile you know Alameda was
holding you know the majority of the
assets especially in the case of of ftt
and even going back to kind of the
origins of ftt a lot of people you know
it's hard to say for sure but it seems
like there's a good likelihood that ftt
was originally created just to fill a
hole in an alameda's balance sheet I
don't know that for a fact but there's a
lot of speculation around that and some
people have some compelling evidence of
that being the case
um but once the balance sheet was leaked
it's unclear you know I'm kind of in the
camp of it was leaked for a reason
um I don't know if it was from someone
in kind of the binance camp or one of
those things it's kind of you know tin
foil hat type of type of question but
um nonetheless it got leaked and
everyone kind of realized that you know
they weren't in the position that that
everyone thought they were and so what
happened after that was Susie had his
Infamous tweet where he basically said
hey look you know this entity is weaker
than we thought they were and therefore
you know kind of our ftt tokens are at
risk uh and also we just don't want to
have exposure to this entity that seems
to be you know kind of not on the up and
up uh I don't I'm kind of in the camp
that I don't think CZ realized you know
how they were completely swimming naked
I think he probably realized there was
you know to some extent some some weird
Behavior going on behind the scenes
um but I doubt he probably knew full-on
that you know they were basically you
know giving Alameda the majority of
their customer deposits
um but after he tweeted out that they
were going to sell their ftt stake which
they got um you know whenever they they
cashed out of their their FTX Equity uh
it caused two things it caused first of
all
um a panic uh on the ftt token itself
everyone said oh my gosh like the only
buyer of this thing is Alameda and FTX
uh and binance is about to dump you know
multi nine-figure bag on the on this you
know already a liquid Market uh and then
the other thing it caused was a bank run
on FTX itself because people began to
wonder hold on does cze know something
you know why why is why is CZ getting
rid of getting rid of his ftt tokens
there must be something that you know
maybe he knows that that we don't uh and
so you saw a massive amount of
withdrawals uh billions of dollars of
withdrawals within the first few days
which got processed originally in the
first like 24 to 36 hours uh but then of
course after that time period they no
longer could process the withdrawals
because they didn't have the capital
um because with the benefit of hindsight
we now know that they lent uh eight to
nine billion dollars of customer
deposits uh to Alameda which was
collateralized with ftt tokens and when
we go back and look on chain and this is
something that we put in the report when
we look at the balance of ftt on
exchanges we see this massive jump in
September and you know at the time SPF
tweeted out he said oh this is just a
natural you know shift of wallets we're
just moving around some wallets which we
now know was was definitely not the case
and what were they doing you you could
see that they were lending out the
customer assets to Alameda and Alameda
had moved the ftt tokens to FTX
basically as collateral for taking on
those customer deposits because there's
no way that if Alameda actually you know
if they had a liquidity issue at the
time
um that they were going to be able to
get that liquidity out of selling off
their ftt tokens because they were the
only buyer of them
um and so you know when you when you
look at when you look at you know the
end of September and you look at the
balance of ftt on exchanges you can see
this huge jump which uh we now know to
be as the day that they ended up
transferring over the customer assets
for for the ftt tokens as collateral
when we see in hindsight the FTX
situation in Alameda
um it didn't stop there like there was
continued contagion we're still seeing
it now
um there's obviously Genesis there's dcg
um there's kind of uh Gemini is uh is
brought into this talk a little bit as
to uh how FTX and Alameda which appears
to be at least based on uh prosecutors
and law enforcement uh a nefarious or
malicious thing where obviously people
have been charged arrested the whole
thing yeah versus dcg and Genesis at
least from what I read online uh and on
Twitter seems more of like got caught in
a bad trade right I don't see people
kind of being like hey this was a
malicious you know intentional thing to
like hurt customers is that your read on
on the two differences hey guys I hope
that you're enjoying this conversation
as you probably realized we don't run
any ads on this show that's right all
the other podcasts all the other YouTube
shows that you watch they have
advertisers we don't have any direct
relationships with advertisers and we
simply create this because we enjoy
doing it now that we do that though we
have a team and if you'd like to support
us one way you can do that is to go
subscribe to the pomp letter it's a
daily letter that I write to about 235
000 people about my personal opinion on
financial markets business technology
and Bitcoin just go to pompletter.com
and you can sign up there I'd love to
have you join us and it's a great easy
way to support the work that the team
and I are doing on a daily basis all
right let's get back into this
conversation yeah I mean you could
question kind of Barry's ethics and
handling the whole thing and you know I
think he's probably very carefully you
know conveying all the potential options
for them but yeah I think it's it's
different than you know what took place
with FTX and Alameda which is flat out
fraud uh I think you know that's
partially just reflected in the time
that it's taken right if you know there
is something to the scale of the FTX
Alameda fraud that would have gotten
sniffed out by now I mean it's been over
a month you know since since Genesis has
paused withdrawals what basically
happened was is that you know Genesis
had a large amount of exposure to three
arrows as I mentioned earlier so they
took a huge hit on that
um and then also they had extended a
loan to dcg
um and so you know what happened was
after the three arrows
um you know loan was was uh defaulted on
dcg basically absorbed the hit to their
balance sheet so now let's kind of come
back to bite dcg and they're now under
you know some immense trouble
um I do think though Barry has several
potential options
um you know they do have several assets
including
um you know their their uh Venture
investments in terms of like different
like crypto protocols I doubt that
they'd be able to get anywhere near the
mark to market value of those on paper
right now
um they also have several Port codes and
you know whether they're full out you
know outright owners they're also
investors and you know numerous
different companies in the space dozens
and dozens of different companies in the
space
um and then on top of that you know they
also have grayscale which is their Cash
Cow and I think
um you know if they if it really came
down to it I think grayscale is probably
the the kind of Crown Jewel of the dcg
Empire it's the last thing that they
would want to get rid of uh but
depending on the multiple that you want
to put on on you know the gbdc trust
you know I think you could argue that
it's worth you know maybe somewhere
between 750 to a billion dollars again
depending on the multiple that you want
to put on it it's also depends on you
know
um what how are you determining what you
know you're saying that their yearly
revenue is
um I know they did almost I think it was
like 750 mil last year and and uh I'm
sorry in 2021
um but you know now obviously that's
significantly lower it's like somewhere
between like two to three hundred mil
um because they were just collecting a
two percent fee on the the Bitcoin that
are sitting in the trust and it's just
absolute gold mine you just sit on
bitcoin and hold it and get paid to do
it
um so I don't know exactly you know also
knowing that dcg is in trouble they
probably wouldn't get the terms that
they'd be looking for if they tried to
sell off grayscale uh but my point is
they have several different potential
assets they can tap into they're also
the largest holder of gbtc and this is
something that they've kind of come
under scrutiny for is that they borrowed
capital from Genesis to make Venture
Investments
um and then also buy back gbtc shares
well I think once G BTC started going
into a discount to try to kind of
backstop backstop the discount and so
you know there's no way that they could
get the full Mark to market value of
those assets in the same way that they
couldn't further Venture Investments as
well
um I think this is why they recently
came out in a letter uh to to grayscale
shareholders
um but they're considering a tender
offer for uh it's a 20 tender offer and
so what that would essentially do is I
don't know exactly how it's I don't know
if they just go down the list of the
largest holders and that's how it's
determined who's able to to participate
in the tender offer but if that is the
case they're the largest holder they own
over four percent of the gbtc supply so
that would benefit them immensely right
they you know they could get I don't
know exactly what the gbtc shares that
they're they're holding are worth today
and some are
um multi multi-9 figures
um so you know that would also help them
Shore up some liquidity so you know I
think I think Barry has some options and
he's definitely assessing all of those
very carefully
um you know people should also keep in
mind that Barry was an old uh he used to
be involved in in bankruptcy uh
restructuring so you know I don't think
this is anything new to him and I tend
to think that you know Barry is one of
the ogs in the space and he'll probably
figure it out but it's definitely come
under an immense amount of scrutiny me
mostly because of the Gemini iron
product which was a retail-facing
product where you know retail are going
on Gemini and seeing Oh I can get you
know seven eight percent yield
um you know this sounds great you know
they're not thinking about you know the
risk going on behind the scenes of
course you have terms of service but
like no one's actually reading what's
you know going on with the assets they
just see you know the the you know
percentage return that they could
generate uh by simply just you know
pushing a button and giving the assets
to Gemini which they perceive as
risk-free so I think that's kind of the
biggest ethical question is you know
should should Barry just expedite the
whole thing to get customer funds back
but at the end of the day I think you
know the cynical reality is that
everyone has their own personal
incentives and Barry's going to try to
look out for himself yeah what about
Bitcoin miners I know you touched on
this in the report and they seem to be
uh kind of taking a back seat because of
all the contagion and that but they
haven't exactly had a great year either
no yeah I think uh this has probably
been the toughest year for Bitcoin
miners ever
um you know when you look at kind of the
variables that go into be you know going
to being a successful Bitcoin miner
you're essentially you know long Bitcoin
spot price and then your short hash rate
and your short energy costs right and so
when we look at the three of those
components I mean they're going in the
complete opposite direction as what you
would ideally want to see right you have
Bitcoin spot price down 75 percent you
have Global Energy prices at multi-year
highs and you have hash rate near
all-time highs uh which has actually
been uh increasing it's come down a bit
over the last few weeks but it's
actually increasing as Bitcoin is
trading down at you know 15 16k which is
absolutely mind-boggling
um and I'm unsure exactly who the entity
is that was piling on hash rate maybe it
was just because you know a lot of these
miners were like financed with debt and
you know previously that wasn't the case
but
um nonetheless I mean that that's just
been uh making the you know outlook for
for minors this year incredibly
incredibly difficult
um so you know there are margins and one
way to look at this is uh through hash
prices you you can compare uh minor
Revenue divided by
um by hash rate and what essentially you
get is
um the price per per Terra hash um and
so when you look at that over time that
perpetually declines because you have
more and more people that want to mine
Bitcoin so it becomes increasingly
difficult to do so
um but we've just over the last few
months uh mid more uh all-time lows
every week I check it it's on a new
all-time low uh basically showing you
that you know margins continue to get
more and more compressed another way to
look at this is something called the
foil multiple with our created by our
buddy David well over at ARC invest what
essentially this looks at is minor
Revenue divided by the 365 day moving
average so you're essentially engaging
you know how much revenue our miners
bring in relative to how much they
brought in over the last year and so
that also is at you know relatively
historically low uh readings in addition
to to Hash price and so
um when we look at you know something
called hash ribbons which looks at two
different moving averages of hash rate
um according to that indicator which
tries to like identify capitulatory
periods for miners we've seen two
capitulatory periods this year for for
minors
the first one took place in June
um at the time you had the 30-day moving
average of hash rate cross below the
60-day moving average of hash rate uh
which was an indication that we entered
a capitulatory period for minors uh
during that time you saw core scientific
uh so I think it was 7 202 BTC for like
170 million in proceeds
um which bought them some time but now
we've you know they weren't able to kind
of weather the storm and we've seen you
know them they're undergoing some type
of restructuring at the moment
um and then you also saw looking at
on-chain data uh you could see that the
kind of minor wallets which basically
the way these these data providers track
them is they can just look at the
coinbase transactions
um you know coming directly from the
Bitcoin protocol as mining rewards and
then tagged the wallets from there to
see you know the heuristics around how
the wallets are moving around and then
get a gauge of okay this appears to be a
minor wallet
um and so when you look at these minor
wallets you could see back in June that
a substantial portion of BTC was also
sold off
we came out of that capitulatory period
and then just entered another one uh
roughly uh roughly a month and a half
ago
um and with that we saw an immense
amount of uh cell pressure come from
miners
um you know tens and tens of thousands
of of BTC were sold onto the market and
then recently over the last week we've
finally seen that 30-day change
um and their Holdings actually flipped
positive so you know potentially kind of
coming out of that period at least at
least temporarily
um you know I think I think historically
it's been a good indicator of of kind of
macro bottoms for BTC this is the same
thing that took place at the end of
2018.
um you know I think that kind of legged
down from 6K to 3K at the end of 2018
was mostly all minor selling you can
also see that you know reflected in in
the on-chain data um and I think I guess
just to kind of like wrap up on on
bitcoin miners I think some of the like
the the key takeaways here are you know
if you are looking at you know
purchasing you know Bitcoin mining
stocks I would say you know look for
miners that have you know fixed energy
contracts right so they're not so
susceptible to the you know crazy
volatility and energy prices that we've
seen this year and also look for miners
that have very low debt
you know with with any company you want
to have some degree of debt to you know
help your growth
um but I think with Bitcoin miners it's
a little different because it's just
such a cyclical business uh the
volatility of Bitcoin and also you know
hash right the hash rate is just
absolutely insane
um so I think you kind of have to
approach you know holding debt on your
balance sheet differently than you would
um traditionally and you know there's a
few I guess I won't name names on the
Pod but there's a couple names that um
you know have fixed energy contracts
have super low debt relative to assets
or relative to equity and so those are
those are the guys that I would keep an
eye on and I think also it's it's a
pretty fair conclusion to make that
you'll probably see a lot of M A in
consolidation uh in the mining space and
then I think the last thing to kind of
hit on with with uh Miners and hash rate
is I think over time you probably see
um if if there was a way to basically
look at the amount of passive hash rate
versus outright mining operations that
were set up to mine I think you probably
see the amount of quote unquote passive
hash rate increase over time as a as a
percentage of overall hash rate
um you know I think as you see guys like
shell and Exxon kind of you know dip
their toes in the water with Bitcoin
mining and you know some of these
entities that are basically whether
they're you know flaring off excess
energy or whatever it may be
um you know take take what you and Jason
were doing for example with the tires
early on with eth mining right
um you know I think uh you'll probably
see a larger portion of people who have
what is essentially you know free energy
or extremely low cost energy
uh tap into Bitcoin mining that you know
maybe maybe Bitcoin mining just you know
wasn't a large enough industry and
Bitcoin was too small for them to even
you know think about getting involved in
it but you know with Bitcoin surpassing
a trillion dollar you know asset class
and of course isn't there right now but
you know still multi-billion dollar a
multi-hundred billion dollar asset class
I think it's large enough now that some
of these bigger energy producers can
step in and kind of use it as a way to
monetize what otherwise would be um you
know wasted energy I think one really
cool example of this is uh the Great
American Mining Company
um when you look at what they're doing
in in the midwest I believe
um you know they have uh what are
essentially
um like you know uh traditional miners
that are out there you know like digging
in the earth actually physically pulling
things out like not Computing with
Bitcoin miners
um and of course you know they're
they're flaring off uh their excess gas
um and you know there's all kinds of
environmental restrictions on you know
how much they can burn off every day and
that also causes a restriction on you
know how on on their profit margin right
because you know if they could operate
24 7 they would but there's restriction
on you know the energy that they're
allowed to burn off into the air
and so you know you bring a Bitcoin
miner out there you say to these guys
hey look you give us this energy for
dirt cheap or you know
um even you know free in some cases
um you know we benefit because we have
super cheap mine we have super cheap
power which allows us to be you know a
profitable Miner and at the same time it
benefits you guys because you're able to
operate for a longer period of time
because you don't have to burn off that
excess energy and so I think I think as
a as a percentage of of hash rate I
think the kind of amount of passive
miners will probably grow over time uh
and so when people talk about you know
oh it is such a bad time to be mining
right now I think at the same time you
know
um as we continue to see these guys who
have just extremely low you know energy
costs come into the space I think
that'll be what kind of drives hash rate
you know into the future
will the public minor stay public or
will they be forced in the private
market like there would be like M A and
kind of these uh take privates just to
get them out of those public markets or
is it the capital markets so important
to them just to survive I don't know
it's it's a really good question right
because like a large portion of the hash
rate that came online
um was largely driven just by debt right
in in the end of 2020 and early 2021 we
saw a lot of the you know big public
miners take on substantial amounts of
debt
um but I also do wonder you know I guess
it just depends on the type of entities
that come in and step in buy would
essentially distressed assets
um and you know maybe you have some of
these larger kind of Trad five firms or
you know big energy firms that step in
and take these guys public I I just
don't exactly know who the entities will
be that come in and step in and do the m
a
when you look forward 2023 and into 2024
how do you feel are you bullish are you
cautiously kind of optimistic and you
think we're gonna go sideways like give
me a little forward-looking uh
perspective
yeah sure I think you know first of all
the Outlook in case for digital assets
is stronger than ever uh you know I
think the FTX situation proved that and
I know there's a lot of kind of you know
Bitcoin Maxi types that you know listen
to this podcast but you know I think you
have to really appreciate if you look at
a lot of these D5 protocols they
continue to operate flawlessly
throughout the entire you know debacle
of FTX and all the other major you know
lenders in the space uh and the reason
for that is you know no one's getting
extended on secure loans off of one
phone call as uh Kyle Davey said that
three arrows was able to do uh you know
it doesn't matter who you are you have
to maintain the the same LTV as everyone
else in these D5 protocols
um you know no one gets any special
treatment based on their connections or
anything like that right uh and so you
know a lot of these protocols just
operated completely flawlessly
um and so I would say you know with that
you know while at the same time you had
all decentralized players blow up the
case for D5 I think is stronger than
ever so that's one thing I would say uh
and then on bitcoin specifically you
know I think the kind of need for
um you know a non-political
asset that is for enemies is stronger
than ever I mean if we look at all the
kind of geopolitical craziness that took
place this year
um you know you now have countries that
are trying to move off a dollar standard
as you know the U.S basically uh said
that they're going to be using Swift as
a weapon moving forward you know that's
kind of their their big bazooka that
they could pull out and they immediately
pulled it out once you know the Russia
uh you know Ukraine situation began to
unfold and it kind of showed their cards
of you know the kind of
um biggest move that they could make
from from like a you know non-uh
non-physical you know War standpoint I
think that was probably the the biggest
move that they could make against the
country without you know physically
going to war with them
um and so I think with that a lot of
countries and this is something China's
known for a while if they've stopped
buying U.S treasuries
um you know you can essentially just get
completely cut off from your you know
reserves and that's what happened in
Russia earlier this year and the entire
you know Financial system and so I think
you have a lot of countries that are
probably waking up to the value
proposition of BTC over the last year
um you know wouldn't be surprised if you
have Sovereign wealth funds or central
banks and you know developing countries
at least that are probably accumulating
some BTC down here
when you think of reflexivity research
you've put together an entire team of uh
various analysts uh you guys are pumping
out a ton of
um research uh I read it every day
obviously uh involved in helping start
the business
um talk a little bit it's like what's
the goal right there's a lot of people
who do research there's a lot of people
who are looking at the space like why is
another research firm needed why I spend
all the time I think this report is uh
what 40 pages uh you know why spend so
much time to put together a 48-page
report yeah sure I think you know when I
when I put together the team
um you know I didn't look at anyone's
credentials
um I didn't even know when I first hired
each of our analysts what their
background really even was you know I
kind of knew vaguely a few things that
they did but it didn't matter to me I
found these guys through Twitter because
they had great Insight uh and I liked
what they put out and you know it was
essentially proof of work right the
crypto says you know proof of work you
know you you put out the information and
let people you know judge you based on
that
um and you know you could be an
anonymous whatever you want to have is
your profile you know a monkey picture
and if you're putting out great stuff
people will find you and that's how
people found me that's how you found me
is I put out an article and you dm'd me
and said hey man I like this let's let's
record a pod right and then ever since
we've we've been good friends
um and you know that's how I found these
guys as well as I just thought they put
out great content on the internet I said
you know let's let's put a group
together of young people who are
completely passionate about the space
and have proven uh that they have great
insight into the space and you know have
a unique perspective
um and so through that we've compiled a
team covering everything from uh Global
macro uh fundamental Bitcoin analysis
um derivatives
um unchain stuff that you know mainly
I'm covering uh and then also defy uh
and even a little nfts in there as well
uh we kind of cover a breadth of
everything that you need to know in the
crypto space
um you know I think when you think about
you know why would you want to you know
purchase a research research
subscription
um you know I think it comes down to the
following you know if you're a hedge
fund or a family office or you know
someone in traditional Finance like an
independent investor that's looking to
get involved in crypto but you just
don't want to take the time to do it
um you could you could bring on a crypto
analyst right how much is that going to
cost you probably 90 100 000 you know
probably less than it did a year or two
ago but you know it's probably gonna
cost you near six figures a year
um and for us you know you can you can
go on our website right now purchase a
subscription a subscription for 2500 and
get access to four to five quality
reports about everything that you need
to know about the digital assets space
you know from a team of analysts that
are constantly surveying the market 24 7
so you don't have to and so when I when
you kind of think of it that way you get
the value of four analysts
um not only through reports but also we
do weekly analyst calls
um for you know a fraction of the cost a
50th of the cost of you know what it
would be to to bring on your own
full-time analysts and so you know that
that's how I would say I think about it
and you know I'm really happy with when
we launched you know we launched what
what I think we both at least hope so is
you know near the you know the trough of
the bear Market
um and you know I think that just kind
of reflects that you know we really do
care about the space and you know we're
here for the long term we didn't launch
us at the peak of the bull market to
make a couple bucks you know I think uh
there's room for especially you know as
people have gotten shaken out over the
last you know 12 to 16 months there's
room for several reputable you know
trusted transparent voices in the space
to step in and really help guide people
particularly in traditional Finance you
know I think there's a lot of kind of
word salad that gets thrown around
there's a lot of weird terms and in
crypto and things like that uh and I
think we kind of really make an effort
to unpack that for our clients and you
know in our weekly analyst calls you
know we answer any questions that they
may have and you know help kind of um
simplify the the you know approach of
coming into this space that you know
quite frankly is pretty overwhelming
when you first step in and so
um you know our kind of goal of
launching the business uh of course as
you know is is that you know we wanted
to help bridge traditional Finance into
the digital asset space and uh think we
could play a big role in doing that
moving forward are you still having fun
of course all right of course man you
know when I when you uh first met me I
was sending out uh tweets and sending
out charts in the bathroom at Target
you were still doing the same thing yeah
just not at Target just not a Target all
right where can we send people to find
you on the internet or if they want to
sign up for reflexivity research where
can I send them sure you can find my
Twitter it's uh W Clementi III
reflexivityresearch.com is where you can
find our research product we've got a
bunch of example reports and then as you
mentioned and when we walk through today
we just also released this 2022 year in
review 2023 Outlook report I cover
everything in that from everything that
took place in global macro and what to
expect in 2023 moving forward with that
uh from our macro analysts and we can
word a lot of things more eloquently
than I can uh covered all the crypto
contagion of this year a lot of the
positive statistics of you know kind of
the silver lining of of bitcoin's
resiliency despite the price drawdown
um a lot of the big kind of mainstream
events that took place you know I think
you know not to turn this into a whole
nother tangent here but I think there
were a lot of kind of things that got
overlooked this year
um you know Fidelity offering Bitcoin to
clients uh BlackRock offering Bitcoin to
clients uh Starbucks integrating nfts in
their Rewards program which is the
largest Rewards program in the world
um you know Visa recently announcing
that they're going to be integrating
starkware into their payments and so I
think there are a lot of positive
developments that took place you know
below the surface we also cover
everything that took place in D5 this
year uh all the trends in terms of
individual protocols
um you know the the kind of Rise of
layer twos how to think about layer twos
versus layer ones and what the potential
multi-chain landscape might look like uh
basically everything you need to know so
you know if you have a little time and
you're looking for a little extra
reading definitely check out that report
on our website and we also have a couple
other example ones as well for you to
check out I love it we'll definitely do
it again in the future thank you so much
absolutely it's fun doing this in person
after the last three years